>> Tucker: BY NOW YOU HAVE
HEARD THE CRUSHING NEWS ABOUT
OUR COLLEAGUE AND DEAR FRIEND
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
I HAVE ONLY A FEW WEEKS LEFT
TO LIVE, CHARLES WROTE IN ONE
OF HIS FINAL LETTERS.
THIS IS THE FINAL VERDICT.
MY FIGHT IS OVER."
OVER THE COMING DAYS CHARLES
WILL BE CELEBRATE AND
ULTIMATELY EULOGIZED BY THOSE
WHO KNEW HIM.
FOR GENERATIONS HE WILL
CONTINUE TO TOUCH AND GUIDE
THOSE WHO DIDN'T KNOW HIM.
HIS WORDS CLEAR AND CRISP AND
TRUE WILL LONG OUTLIVE HIM.
A LOT WILL BE SAID ABOUT
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADD ONE THING.
OVER THE MORE THAN 20 YEARS I
KNEW HIM, CHARLES THOUGHT
ABOUT DEATH EVERY DAY.
HE TOLD ME THAT ONCE.
IF THAT SOUNDS MORE -- MOROSE,
IT'S THE OPPOSITE.
HE WAS ONE OF THE RARE PEOPLE
WITH THE COURAGE TO LOOK
REALITY SQUARELY IN THE FACE.
CHARLES RADIATED A CALM
CHEERFULNESS.
HE KNEW WHAT WAS COMING.
HE HAD BEEN CLOSE TO IT
BEFORE.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE, BUT
IT DIDN'T SCARE HIM.
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER IS A
GENUINELY BRAVE MAN.
FOR THAT REASON, HE IS A HAPPY
MAN.
"I LIVE THE LIFE THAT I
INTENDED," HE WROTE.
"THERE IS NO HIGHER
ACHIEVEMENT THAN THAT."
GOOD NIGHT.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.